là de ce côté là pourquoi c'est c'est un
problème le réchauffement
climatique sensibilisé au métier de
l'énergie un bus itinérant était
stationné dans la cour du collège le
village à trappe ce lundi 27 novembre
objectif faire découvrir aux élèves les
multiples débouchés de ce secteur en
pleine croissance emploi de techniciens
d'ingénieurs ou de commerciaux 50000
postes devrai être créés en France d'ici
à 2030 moins d'énergie fossile beaucoup
plus d'énergie renouvelable pour faire
cette transition on a besoin de beaucoup
de monde de beaucoup de compétences et
nous nous sommes dit que il fallait
qu'on aille à la rencontre des
collégiens parce qu'en fait c'est en 3e
qu'on commence à réfléchir vraiment à
son orientation à faire les choix
d'études et puis plus tard le choix d'un
métier des voocations à suscité dès le
plus jeune âge fiche de post formation
ou salaire après une présentation des
enjeux sur la transition énergétique les
collégiens ont pu interroger ces
différents professionnels en activités
par des énergies carboné cé intéressant
ça ça on dirait ça nous a un peu testé
sur nos connaissances
et on a truc par exemple moi je savais
pas tout ce qui était biomasse et tout
ça pratiquement tous les métiers je les
connaissais pas
et je je vivais comme si il y avait
personne qui s'en occupa mais derrière
il y a quand même pas mal de gens qui
s'en occupent attrape on porte un projet
de chaleur géothermique concrètement ça
veut dire que dans quelques années des
trapistes potentiellement seront amenés
à être salariés dans des entreprises qui
opéreront le réseau de chalur
géothermique donc c'est des débouchés
pour ces gamins plus de 200 élèves de
l'établissement ont
à cette journée de rencontre le bus
pédagogique IDEX collge tour poursuivra
sa tournée franilienne jusqu'au 8
décembre
prochain